Good morning Hank,
it's Thursday
And the greatest ever Pizzamas,
at least in terms of shirt sales,
is about to come to an end.
That's right Hank,
nothing lasts forever
Not even cold November rain and
tomorrow marks the end of
week daily videos and soon you will
be unable to get this shirt
or any of the other amazing
Pizzamas stuff available at
Pizzamas.com right now but
only for the next couple days.
Now listen Hank, I don't want to end
my part of Pizzamas on a bummer note
but I do have to take next
week off from Vlogbrothers
Because I'll be traveling with my family
Specifically, I'll be traveling to
England to see my friend
Mike Birbiglia perform
comedy and my football team
AFC Wimbledon perform tragedy
Or at least that's what the
betting odds would indicate
But you never know with Wimbledon
America's second  favorite
fourth tier English soccer team,
that most people
in this community keep up with
via updates on Dear Hank and
John, our hit podcast that
unfortunately has been on
cancer hiatus for the last
several months, which means
that most of y'all probably
don't know what's happening
with AFC Wimbledon
Single sentence backstory for anyone
who's new, my producing partner
Rosianna and I sponsor
a fourth tier English soccer team
called AFC Wimbledon who
play in South London
And who are owned by their fans
each of whom pay about $25 a year
In order to vote on the club's leadership
Because of that sponsorship,
Wimbledon's women's team play
with a Partners in Health logo
on the back of their shirts
and the men's team play with a DFTBA
logo on the back of their shorts
in that liminal space
between left thigh and buttock
The other thing you need to
know about AFC Wimbledon
is that we're bad
Like, there are other teams in
the fourth tier of English football
who are owned by major Hollywood
celebrities, or the Saudi government,
but we are owned by our fans and
so we never have any money
So we've got a beautiful new
stadium owned and built by the fans
that's packed every week
What we don't have is
uh... money
So we're pretty bad every year
We used to be a third tier
English soccer team
but then we got relegated down to
the fourth tier because we were so bad
and then we barely survived in
the fourth tier last season
and this season wasn't looking
like it was going to be any different
except something
weird happened which is that
uh...
we seem like we might be good?
Like, not to brag, but if you
look at the table currently
AFC Wimbledon are narrowly
ahead of Wrexham
the football club owned by
Ryan Reynolds and Rob McElhaney
and we're several spots above
the franchise currently plying
its trade in Milton Keynes
Also, and this is even more surprising,
we're fun to watch this season
We have exciting young players
who score lots of goals
and also a mountain of a man
who rolls his shorts up so much
that you can't even see our logo
but more on him in a second
So our star players this year include our
striker Ali al-Hamadi
who left Iraq
as an infant after his dad was imprisoned
by the Saddam Hussein regime
and now has become an
Absolute superstar for both
AFC Wimbledon
and the Iraqi national team
I just love him so much.
Also we have
the mustachioed James Tilly
who scored seven goals
in his first nine games for us
And out on the other wing we've got
Aaron Sassu, an 18 year old
who's been playing for Wimbledon's
youth side since he was 10
In fact, there are a bunch of great players
emerging from our academy
Our fullbacks include
my personal hero Jack Curry, who's also
played with us since he was 10
and also Isaac Ovandera,
who joined us at the age of 14
We're never gonna be
the kind of football club that
can buy big stars, so we're
gonna have to make them
and we've done a
really good job of that
And then we have our central defenders
Ryan Greatbeard Johnson
and Mighty Joe Lewis
Joe Lewis, the man
with the golden shorts.
Joe "Shortshorts" Lewis
Joe "big man, small shorts" Lewis
Joe "we're only here for the shorts" Lewis
Look at how aggressively this man
rolls up his shorts
You cannot see our DFTBA logo
and I, for one, am fine with it
The great thing about AFC Wimbledon is that
If you love an underdog story
we keep on delivering
because we're always going
to be an underdog story
But the argument we've been making
in the 10 years we've been
sponsoring AFC Wimbledon
and the 21 years since AFC
Wimbledon reformed
after being told by the English FA that
there was no place for a
football club in that community
community-held assets,
communal action can work
It's not easy, it doesn't
always work, but it can work
I know it's just a football club, but what I've
learned from AFC Wimbledon,
not just on the field but also
their local action group that
seeks to address
poverty in the community
and the AFC Wimbledon Foundation
what I've learned from them
I've used and we've used in a lot
of our community projects
including trying to get folks to lower
the prices of TB diagnostics and treatments
And I'll tell you what, I'm sure we're
not gonna be good all season
I'm sure we're gonna lose a bunch of our best
players in the January transfer window, etc.
But oh my gosh, is it fun when we're good
And holy crap, I love Pizzamas
Thanks for coming up with
this weird idea, Hank.
I'm gonna savor saying this since
I won't get to say it for a year
I will see you tomorrow